well people can find me
uh best on my website because
unfortunately
although i try to distribute
uh you know scientific information and
only scientific information it gets
increasingly
blocked on all kinds of uh channels and
media
so um my
my website is uh gear fandom bosch
and then um dot org
o rg okay
gertvandenbusch.org i know that you're
also
on twitter and that your website can be
found through your twitter
bio i will say to the extent that people
that platforms are taking down the
material that you're putting up
this is madness yeah i know right this
is madness
you are a domain expert
you are clearly
motivated by concern
what you're saying is whether or not
it is correct it is perfectly rational
it is highly logical and can be
interpreted by anyone
who has uh the scientific
training enough to follow such an
argument
that the idea that you are somehow
a hazard by virtue of
engaging in very serious questions on
which a great deal of
human well-being rests is preposterous
these these
platforms are in no position to evaluate
what you're saying
and that means we have to be able to
discuss it
uh in public well that is what i'm
calling for since many many weeks
because the the
the way the discussion is conducted
right now
is that uh well some fact checkers
reach out to some experts and then you
have some one-liners
in their report some one-liners that so
to say contradict what i'm saying
and then the fact-checker confronts me
with this kind of
uh you know contradictory statements so
to say
that is not a discussion and that is and
i i'm asking
all the time you know for these experts
to
to to to to start a debate right uh like
we are
like we are discussing then things can
be clarified
and uh you know arguments can and and we
could i would love to see a consensus on
what are the what is going to be the
the the criteria that we all agree upon
to say whether or not human intervention
is driving
this this is thriving immune escape
right because if there is really
immune escape driven by human
intervention in the way we have been
discussing
then i think everyone will agree that
this is not a good thing
this is really very problematic but if
we don't have
criteria and if we don't agree upon i
mean the only thing
will be vaccinate everybody right
till not everybody is unless everybody's
vaccinated
it's not over right and and that cannot
be
according to my interpretation no and
the pressure to vaccinate everybody is
incredible
the number of uh young people that i
hear
are being vaccinated is preposterous in
light of the fact that there's really
almost no reason to do it even even if
the
vaccine is as safe and good as it's
being portrayed
it uh the fact is young people
are already immune and there's no reason
to inter intervene in the
is this was certainly the case
when the wild strain came in and and i
told my kids you know
uh okay if you have if you're obliged to
because you know you have to wear a mask
in the store for example you have to do
this but don't do it
when you are with friends etc and they
are not
they were not participating in mass
gathering gatherings anyway
but now the problem now is with these
highly infectious variants
the likelihood is increasing that
well this is something we didn't discuss
but it's important to understand
when you are an asymptomatic
uh asymptomatically infected so you got
infected
with the virus without developing
symptoms
during a short period in time you will
be developing antibodies
right these are antibodies that are not
very mature
and i'm not saying in all
asymptomatically infected people but in
a fair extent a fair number of
asymptomatically infected people
they will develop antibodies that are
not fully mature and that are
short-lived
so as we as we discussed these
antibodies
will be able to bind to this protein
not neutralize it but out compete
your innate immune response so now with
a highly infectious variant circulating
the likelihood that as a young guy
or lady you get the hit by the virus
during that time where you are sitting
on your immature antibodies becomes
increasingly higher right
and that is how we now also see how
younger age groups without underlying
diseases
people in perfect health get severe
covet
right so you see these are criteria
for me that are really important to
analyze and to further discuss and to
agree upon
if that is not done and the only
criterion is
we go until everybody gets vaccinated
young or old no matter what
no matter what you know whether they're
in good health or or whatever whether
they're serious positive or set or
negative
i mean then it's it's yeah it's it's
really a war situation
right yeah well that's that's very
frightening all right well this has been
a fascinating discussion
um i look forward to hearing how this
develops and i do hope that people
i i know people are taking your argument
seriously
privately i think there's a lack of
courage in
especially in and around academia where
people won't necessarily say what they
understand because they're afraid of
consequences and in this case
the consequences for humanity are so
immense that i think
it is incumbent on people to um
to at least point out that this is an
argument that needs to be taken very
seriously well
there are top experts
much more famous than i am who i know
and who write me that's you know i'm
right
but if you're really a top expert
of course you are working in some of
these
communities that are now or you know
deeply involved in in driving these
vaccination campaigns
so unfortunately these people cannot
speak up and i i think it's it's
really given what is at stake
it is yeah i i for me it's a moral
obligation uh you know i could be
employed i could be
whatever you know i mean this is so
frightening to me
i i have spent uh
weeks and weeks and nights to understand
what is going on and
uh so
you know having done my homework the
moral obligation to react is such that
you know that this is for me the
absolute prior
priority no matter what well
i agree with you about the moral
obligation of it
um it's of course not entirely safe for
me to put you on my channel either i
feel that same moral obligation and i
would just point out
that i think we've lost track
of how much risk people have taken
through history when something was
important and to the extent that people
may have
fears about what happens career-wise to
them if they speak an important truth
they need to recognize that lives are on
the line
this is an argument that must be engaged
and it's time for them to step
up and i would say to the extent that
there are people who privately
acknowledge that what you're saying
is sensible people who believe you are
right and are in a position to change
uh public opinion i open this channel to
them if they'd like to come on and
and tell us uh what you've got right
what you've got wrong
what they think we ought to understand
i'm more than happy to
to host that discussion well i much
appreciate that uh brett i
i really do and yeah i'm also very much
hoping for
people ultimately because it's really
it's really more than time to do so
because
as you as you will realize right now
things start to
be very fast to evolve very very fast if
you see in some countries because that
is the only the other thing every
country is looking
at its own situation when i hear the
news for example in belgium it's like
the only country where uh where we have
uh
a coffee fandom right and and the world
is closing in on us
and it's like i mean if there is a
double mutant in
in india that is resistant for example
that is also my problem that is your
problem that is everyone's problem
and it's like oh let's let's uh let's
put the figures down let's try to to put
a figure down in in in belgium or in
germany or in the uk
right if if there was ever a situation
in which we should put politics aside
put national boundaries aside and team
up
to address a problem this is it yeah
pandemic is for definition a global
thing
and our strategy is not global at all
right
uh yeah well you know we
we could go on forever at this but uh i
much appreciate uh
you doing this and uh at least giving me
an opportunity to talk about this and
frankly speaking i think
bret we have been very scientific about
this right i mean
yep yeah so um yeah
i think we have we have to um to
continue
to have this discussion and i must say i
greatly appreciate your
courage and your insight i think uh
you're a force for good and i
uh i am so glad that you chose to come
on darkhorse
yeah thank you so much
you